she didn't need to be a muslim woman
to remind me to get it together
[Music]
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
their products are fantastic health
supplements and also from the sunnah
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salaam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamu alaikum brothers and sisters
and dear friends
very important topic we discussed today
sister halima aiden
somali sister who like many young people
be it men or women male or female
who go on a journey where they sometimes
make mistakes and they learn from those
mistakes
and the best of sinners are those who
repent
brothers and sisters so we're going to
go through her
instagram story which was sent to me and
we just want to
react to and learn some lessons because
recently i've been reading a book called
uh beauty sick and it correlates
beautifully
with the sisters decision they are so
panels how to bless her i didn't really
know much about her but let's get
straight into inshallah
and here we go yep so this was a story i
screen recorded it
so the first thing that she put here was
what a literal queen
rakaya ahmed aiden my mom asked me to
quit modeling a long time ago
i wish i wasn't so defensive sis was
literally the only person who had the
purest intentions for me
the advice she gave me was deen over
dunya
and her stance has never changed
our mothers are always those who always
stand
behind us no matter what mistakes we
make
so may allah bless her mother
and all the mothers because they go
through so many sacrifices for us
and may allah bless all of them wallahi
and like once scholar said
half of the nation are female and they
give birth to the other half
let's carry on so this picture she says
another theme i'm noticing is that my
faith was the strongest around my family
just look at that gilbert
so this is is the sister on a story is
telling well she's
on her story instagram story she's
giving us her story
of a hijab story three stories in a
sentence
okay so she's expressing how she felt
strong like had the actual
uh hijab on at those times so let's go
on to the next one a group
picture so there's four nuns i don't
know if they're nuns but all these
people who do fancy dresses
and dressed up as nuns but anyways heck
it was on point here too because i still
knew who i was
deep next one genuinely the last time i
was truly happy and content with my
hijab
journey okay so she's genuinely coming
from the bottom
of her heart okay this picture is of a
young person that looks up to her
and she's posting that as something that
she looks up to
and it goes and this is her statement to
the young sister may allah bless her
look at her hijab mashallah so beautiful
like the one i used to wear
she's talking about sister halima is
talking about this young sister here
and look at the representation i gave to
her
deep down sis can't relate honestly same
goes for me
subhanallah one thing that we admire and
we don't see much of
is those who come up come out whoever
you might be male or female come up come
out and say you know what
what i did was wrong and acknowledge
that rather than justifying it and this
is something that
should be admired and looked up to next
one
so this one is as you guys can see on
the screen i used to justify a lot
wow well i don't even know i was just
talking about justification i just came
over
it's a panel i used to justify a lot as
we as we ever needed these brands brands
to represent hijabis
they need us never the other way around
but i was just so desperate
back then for any representation that i
lost touch with who i was
okay i don't need my class to read this
so i'm just to kill him because
i can read close up he cannot read
yeah so now this is very interesting so
they get her to do modeling
and she's got jeans over her head in a
hijab
like hijab sense um and then she sees
what she says but
the cup obviously says find your style
but this isn't even my style
never was why did i allow them to put
jeans
on my head when at the time i had only
ever worn skirts and long dresses this
is deep
she's saying i don't even wear jeans as
trousers
and they're making me put it on my head
that's deep you know like what's she
saying
deep stuff and this picture
i went back to my hotel room and just
sobbed after the shoot because deep down
i knew this wasn't
it but was too scared to speak up also
very common struggle when you are the
first to do something
like what was that hideous green grass
thing on my head
i don't know what okay i don't know what
it is but there you go
i should have just politely declined
this because where is the hijab
subhanallah you know you can see
and when i was talking about the book
the it's called beauty sick and i
recommend
every single sister please please well
if i if i had the money i'll buy it all
of you guys yeah but i don't
buy the book the book is so so important
yeah i can't remember the person who
wrote he wrote it but she says there was
200
000 girls interviewed over 40 countries
and she was saying that 90 of them were
not
they were not happy with one part or
another of their body
can you imagine that she was talking to
girls that was so skinny
so skinny in her book yeah this i'm not
talking about the system
in her book that they would starve their
self they would eat
certain little like things whether it
may be
crisps or snacks or whatever just so the
brain signals the the stomach like yeah
you're full
just so like look at the enslavement and
this is the reason why so many women
come to islam why
but you need to think to yourself why is
it that islam is represented as the
barbaric religion that beats the wife
and kills her and all that kind of
madness
but most of the women that come to islam
most of the people that come to islam
are females
from the western nations what is forcing
them to come
to come to islam because the enslavement
that they are in
the invisible shackles that they have to
carry day in day out you can't go
outside
without makeup you have to look a
certain way the societies made you feel
more ugly and ugly and you need to look
a certain way and dress up certain like
this and look like that and do your hair
spending hours in front of a mirror you
think you're fat you're subhan allah
wallahi the
the distress the the the can you imagine
living like that botox i need to get my
lips done i need to get this done muslim
sisters are falling for this today
i know the struggle is rule i can never
relate how the hijab is
hats off to you guys literally but the
thing is brothers and sisters and
sisters who are watching this
while be free
you would only find we all enslaved to
something
you only find true freedom when you
enslave yourself to the one that has
created you
that's the reason why when you wear the
jilbab you're not objectified or
sexualized this is even though some
feminists will disagree with it
because when a man is talking to you
he's talking to you not talking to
you or whatever else is present there
brothers and sisters the hijab is there
to uplift women
yeah now this doesn't mean that allah
has legislated that allah didn't say
women cover up because men can't lower
the gays no
men have to lower the gates regardless
of how you dress the point is that it's
there to uplift and honor you
and you're not a sexual object let's
carry on
so i took what you all said to heart and
probably misinterpreted it as well
i remember wanting to be the hot hijabi
as if that didn't just defeat the whole
purpose a hot mess
is what it it was truth it was
truthfully
spanish for honesty looking back now i
did what i said i would never do
which is compromise who i am in order to
fit in thank you hoyo
thank you for never giving up on me if i
continued down this path i would have
definitely lost my hijab completely
hoyo we respect you big up
may allah bless you uh auntie from uk
to america wherever you are may allah
bless you
while he for never giving up on your
daughter regardless of what others said
and in this picture it says i don't know
if it says eu
child the confusion was real on this day
i thought my entire team
i fought my entire team to wear this
look and even
denise was like this isn't the real you
who's denise we're gonna find out who
denise is this is very interesting
that's how rebellious i was feeling at
the time the the pressure was getting
unbearable and i'm sad to say i went
through a period of representing the
hijab
this is vogue magazine yeah she said she
had to delete this
off my page because honestly this wasn't
representation this was mockery and i am
so sorry i was too young and naive to
see it back then
but at the time i justified it because
look it's vogue
arabia but wrong is wrong no matter how
hard you try to convince yourself may
allah bless you sister
subhanallah how many people that we have
today who
use the hijab you know and justify it
you know to to sit to sales or reach
fame or whatever etc subhanallah and
this is the same you know what
this is not the hijab we know may allah
bless her
and here also never again taking a job
that will require me to change my scarf
style just to show off a necklace i'm a
hijab wearing woman
i can wear rings and bracelets but i
what but what i
but what do i need a necklace for
and this one says i really thought damn
i did that not even realizing how much i
was hurting the little hijabi i used to
be by now showing the world
a new standard for hijab that could be
comfortable with essentially erasing my
hijab completely
and that caption should have read boo
boo the clown
super look how hard she's criticizing
her own self
because she understands the damage bro
and sisters and sometimes when we're
given these opportunities as sisters
or brothers whatever it may be when a
big brand comes armani came
to me oh and says yeah you have to do
this but you just need to cut your beard
get lost buff bounce yourself i don't
give you armani flipping gucci
uh parada i don't give a damn when your
iman
comes first you do not look up because
you don't feel inferior oh my gosh our
money came to me
because it's a big company and that's
what happens we hear it we feel
inferiority complex
yeah this colonial mind oh you know you
know i need to
subhan allah and this is what's
happening do not
brother says because what happens is
allah will communicate with that very
thing
that you put before him here this is a
very powerful one this is so powerful
denise that she was talking about is
that yo in the back
look how have a shock of her face yeah
and
sister halima herself with message
because denise has been with me since
day one of my career
and looking back sis really had my back
always
she tried to talk to me out of so many
looks but i was too busy trying
to look cute and feel accepted her face
her face says it all
and she didn't need to be a muslim woman
to remind me to get it together
let's read that again she didn't need to
be a muslim
woman to remind me to get it together
how many times you see non-muslims
looking at hijabis and haram
relationships
or whatever it may be or doing things
and they're thinking you're not supposed
to do that your origin doesn't teach you
that right
and non-muslim telling you
deep now i started off so strong but no
worries i'm coming back
may allah keep you from sister inshallah
subhanallah and
what like islam us look at that marshall
well it's absolutely amazing
and she says yeah halima what was the
reasoning but honestly i'm glad i went
through all the confusion because now i
can warn you guys
about where i went and where i made the
wrong turns she's telling you sisters
out there
she made these mistakes don't do the
same don't go there and
learn your lesson she's done it
and here she's talking about this was
this is where i went right getting to me
other fellow hijab is doing remarkable
things and breaking stereotypes that's
it
you know just because you know you don't
you don't need to fit into this
this culture this society as a hijabi
when you can do so much i don't
understand why people feel like
it's all about beauty if you read the
book the beauty sick you will see
that she says that a woman only known
for beauty
yeah is this what you is that all you're
known for can you imagine
as a woman the only thing you know is
about your beauty oh you're taking i
think good care of your hair
a skin a disc or that wallahi
if we gave if our sisters if our sisters
gave
ten percent of the effort they give on
their skin
their eyebrows their hair that i then
the lens are going to i
the botox the the the gym to look the
this which color hijab uh this clothing
that wallahi
the effort that they go through and so
the brothers i'm just talking in this
specific topic
if we give 10 of that to our soul
and nearly finishing off diversity where
i was too afraid to ask back then but
not today satan
plus bring back the smiles because you
all made us look like half dead soulless
gremlins
subhan allah and i'm going to finish off
with this brothers and sisters because i
think this was very very powerful
um and we've got some idiotic person
here saying please don't take advice
from your mom she's not educated you
just stopped your own bag
you could have built generational wealth
sad
when somebody's whole happiness and
motivation or objective in life
is to think that money makes you happy
you'll have idiotic comments like this
to think that money is going to bring
you happiness and this is a brilliant
reply from sister halima
to someone i don't know who it is maybe
some this
industry someone in the industry you all
had and will finish on this
you all had four years to learn about me
and why did you never remind me once to
facetime my mom
or even ask for yourself why did you
guys make me feel like i had to abandon
my mum
you put your whiteness into my brand you
white-washed my hijab
i came to you at my most vulnerable and
you used it to control me and basically
ride my coattail
all the way to the bank but i found my
real hijab say thank you for allah
say thank you so thank you for allowing
me to wake up finally
and like we said before brothers and
sisters she has come to the realization
subhanallah
and how she was in a vulnerable state
and was taken advantage of
and this happens in the what kind of
industries pornography industry
you name it they take advantage of you
give you all these promises
use and abuse you and then bye-bye don't
need you anymore
next please brothers and sisters
we ask allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to
bless sister haleema's mom
hoyo and um we ask allah keep sister
halima firm
and i ask every single one of you guys
please sisters read the book
beauty sec you are all beautiful in your
own way
do not let this society make you feel
ugly
do not try to reach a standard that
you're never going to reach
you're never going to reach it never be
happy with yourself
find true freedom within yourself
connect yourself to allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
because indeed with the remembrance of
your lord
of allah do do hearts find peace
we are created in this way nothing
brothers and sisters as in this life of
all these materialistic things
allah is telling us that only with the
remembrance of allah do find peace
same as when we go into jannah we're
going to seek allah's face
and when allah shows his self to us the
way he feels his majesty
that we're going to that's going to be
the most amazing thing nothing in jannah
is going to be equivalent to that
so just in this dunya we seek allah's
pleasure and that is what brings us
absolute happiness
bro and sisters allah's promising to us
in jannah when you're gonna have
everything you want
but seeing allah's face and seeking his
face
subhanallah till next time assalamu
alaykum
please send this video to sister halima
may allah bless her inshallah and
yeah goodbye